après trois années en sommeil forcées
les chars du carnaval de Mantes là vont
faire leur grand retour ce dimanche dans
les rues de cette petite commune du
Lochois un événement très attendu par
les bénévoles qui se consacrent à leur
décoration et par les festivaliers qui
devront cette année s'habiller aux
couleurs des années 60 elle est à
Turquie et rendue sur place pour
assister au dernier préparatifs
le compte à rebours est lancé dans
quelques jours les 10 nouveaux chars du
carnaval de mantelan défileront dans les
rues alors chacun est à son poste avant
le jour J bon ici bah c'est de
travailler surtout tout ce qui est
ferraille modifier tout ce qui est
support c'est les derniers préparatifs
on est obligé de renommer un petit peu
parce que depuis trois ans qu'on sort
pas l'humidité un petit peu gagne un
petit peu les sujets les chats géants
attendent sagement depuis 2019 et les
bénévoles aussi ils sont plus de 80 le
jour du défilé et une vingtaine toute
l'année il faut être organisé pour fêter
le grand retour du plus ancien carnaval
de la région on a eu la tempête
donc on a du mal à repartir mais ça y
est on les repart ça y est on est très
content de attendre dimanche pour faire
la grande fête voilà on attend ça avec
impatience enfin un ouf de soulagement
et une belle récompense pour cette
équipe parce que c'est le but c'est de
sortir et de faire voir ce qu'on fait
parce que c'est voilà c'est notre
travail c'est la plus belle joie qu'on
peut avoir c'est de le partager avec la
population après le thème de cette
édition les années 60 entre elles vissé
Brigitte Bardot le défilé réserve une
autre petite nouveauté l'articulation
des bras et des jambes de la mascotte
Monsieur Carnaval chose qui était
impossible jusqu'à maintenant je vais
quand même cette idée-là depuis des
années de dire bah quand même arrivé et
là l'opportunité d'un nouveau plateau a
permis l'accessibilité de par en dessous
pour le pour l'articulation ça donne une
vie autre pour le public en espérant un
rayon de soleil le rendez-vous est pris
dimanche à 15h pour profiter du défilé
avec un tarif unique fixé à 5 euros